what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar to discuss the latest craziest
developments in the one piece story
things are moving fast and so many crazy
things are happening with kaido right
now
so make sure to stay tuned for that if
you do enjoy seeing these weekly
one-piece reviews and want to keep them
coming the best thing you can do is
smash that like button until it's blue
like jinbe if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell or you will miss
future one-piece videos
lastly as you impatiently wait for the
next chapter to drop feel free to check
out my growing one piece playlist where
i got videos about the yonko
warlords supernovas zone logia and
paramecia fruits
and even a video about how strong kaido
is find all those videos and more in my
one piece playlist
link in the description now let's jump
into this glory
spoilers and all we got luffy on the
cover of this week's shonen jump sharing
some ice cream with the other
protagonists and you know we don't
really have to talk about the cover but
i really love how much fun they have
with these covers sometimes
it's not just a neglected side thing
they do try to make them fun
inviting and creative and i appreciate
that i couldn't help but pick out my
first shonen jump
issue 13 years ago when i saw yugi
holding a blue eyes ultimate dragon
they were giving one away and being the
blue eyes stand that i am
i had to have it fast forward 13 years
and i'm still looking forward to the
next shonen jump issue
cover and all anyways my life story and
the history of sean and jump aside
we get a colored one-piece spread this
time around definitely an
upbeat party-esque one where we got the
words we're gonna live like tomorrow
doesn't exist
to me luffy stands out the most with his
big grin and nami looking hella fine
we're gonna live like tomorrow doesn't
exist is awesome and reminds us to live
in the present this is not some kind of
advice to do bad things because you
don't need to worry about the
consequences
no if we look at one piece this is about
living life to the fullest because you
never really know
if you're gonna get tomorrow and that's
true in life just as it is when you're
fighting to yonko
chapter 987 is called faithful servant
we jump into a flashback and see the
moment when kaido got scarred by odin
and when odin
in the manliest of ways survived being
boiled while carrying his retainers and
then launched them in the air so they
could escape
they cried as they ran and kaido looked
serious and annoyed but
not my boy odin like the most epic dudes
around goldie roger socrates cato
odin didn't fear death he smiled as
kaido prepared to kill him and told him
not to underestimate his samurai
odin didn't care whether or not he was
forgotten because his soul
will live yes it would live on in the
action of his retainers but it also goes
beyond that like a ripple in the water
his spirits spread to the point where it
even infected kaido's own daughter
and besides all that there's just
something so inspiring about characters
who smile and won't break down even when
the enemy has their lives
in his hands we continue where we left
off after the flashbacks which were for
our benefit but also to let us know
what's going on from kaido's perspective
right now
he's not unfazed odin is still haunting
his mind the red scabbards
actually manage to penetrate the flesh
of the yonko and draw blood
kiku goes through a hand and kinemon
draws blood too
kaido the unkillable can still bleed and
does
and what odin said about not
underestimating the nine scabbards that
applies to us as much as it does to
kaido
let's be honest did we expect that the
red scabbards would make kaido bleed
freak out and scream from their attack
like this i can't say i did
and in many ways this moment sobers us
up when it comes to the perception
of kaido's invincibility but it also
gives the scabbards the moment they
deserved
they were not useless they did not wait
and plan for nothing
odin was right they cannot be
underestimated and by the same token we
should not
overestimate the untouchability of kaido
either kaido has been mentally scarred
by odin even more so than physically
he feels the wound owed and inflicted on
him it hurts his eyes are wide
and bloodshot you can see fear in his
sweating face
he is shocked that our boys can stab him
and he screams
the yonko feared as the strongest
creature screams
let that sink in kaido comments that
they have odin's haki
and they are thus able to harm him they
come crashing to the ground below
and people are shocked this has set the
perfect possible tempo for this war
how you start out often sets the tone of
the battle kaido is clearly showing us
the importance of the mental side of the
battle as well
as the physical side it's hard to get
motivated or develop morale
when everyone thinks that it's hopeless
or that they'll lose without
accomplishing anything
if kaido had just brushed off their
swords and killed all the red scabbards
right there
this would be a very different fight but
that's not what happened
everyone saw the great yonko bleed sweat
scream
they saw fear in him and now our side is
pumped up
while kaido's crew is probably shocked
and confused
seeing a weakness if only momentarily in
their yonko
through this act alone the red scabbards
have already accomplished something
significant that shouldn't be overlooked
just as people are speculating that
there may be more intruders
hyogoro makes his presence known even at
retirement age this dude is willing to
pick up a sword
for what's right for what he believes in
and for his own principles
props to him and there are many props
worthy moments in this chapter so let's
keep going
big mom in what can only be taken in a
lighthearted way
seems to observe that this party is
really dangerous and questions if kaido
died
i assume this is her speech bubble she
has shown respect to kaido's strength
before
so she knows how hard he'll be to kill
but still
you get a sense that big mom is very
unfazed and practically smiling about
what's happening
definitely the opposite of kaido's
freaked out face that we saw recently as
yamato is rushing with luffy to attack
kaido while he's weak
ulti gets in the way as far as cat
fights go the ones between
these two are pretty brutal ulti is
still upset because yamato knocked her
out in one hit
although it clearly didn't leave lasting
damage luffy also recognized ulti as
quote unquote the headbutt and the
headbutt girl is becoming quite a fan
favorite her blatant straightforward
manner very much reflects luffy's own
and she's a cute but tough dino girl so
what's not to like
yamato then says the day has come to
become kozuki odin and ulti says what
we're all thinking
i don't get it and she also adds are you
an idiot idiot or not
i'm definitely wondering why yamato
doesn't just say stuff like i'm inspired
by lord odin
or i want to carry out odin's will or i
want to be like odin no
she straight up says she is odin does
this possibly have something to do with
odin saying his soul
will live on to kaido let me know what
you guys make of this
is ulti right is yamato just being an
idiot or is there something more to it
the fact that kaido treated yamato so
badly in the past
like almost blowing her up and hitting
her seems to be related with kaido
suffering ptsd from odin and yamato
insisting to be that very enemy he's so
fierce
while beast pirates are trying to warn
yamato that kaido has been attacked
she straight up lets them know that she
is no longer an ally of the beast
pirates
and that she doesn't care if her father
dies after all he was ready to kill her
with the explosive as ulti and yamato
clash
this time on seemingly more equal
footing big mom screams out luffy's name
we got luffy face to face with iyanko
but luffy just tells her he's busy right
now yonko or not
one does not simply interrupt luffy when
he is busy this is reminiscent to me of
when he ran into mihawk at marineford
and thought that he was too busy trying
to save ace at the time
to take on such a strong opponent it's
not really about luffy being scared he's
just got other priorities at this moment
and such a strong opponent being in his
way is definitely inconvenient
in the meantime nami and carrick decide
to run away from the homies and
they do so without any problems in the
process they prove that they can fend
for themselves for the most part and
they won't slow luffy down
obviously throw in a yonko or a
commander and it won't go that easily
but in this case it works out
big mom tells luffy that she's come from
far away
just to kill him making it known where
her main priority lies
this is luffy's influence right here he
can influence one of the strongest
pirates in the world to drop
everything and chase him the strongest
beings become obsessed with him
that speaks volumes about luffy's
current influence in the world of one
piece no matter how his physical
strength currently matches up with
kaidos and big moms
back to kaido who was hurt but is
clearly not down for the count
he realized that orochi's so-called
delusions were true the red scabbards
were in the shadows of the straw hats
who kaido acknowledges us as enemy
that's pretty lit
as well you ain't getting a yonko to
acknowledge every pirate
as an enemy you gotta be special for
that kaido never expected the scabbards
to team up with pirates and he tells
them that pirates will betray them
as soon as they start losing they'll run
clearly this seems to be the way kaido
views the world he betrayed orochi by
saying this
he also implies that he's willing to
betray big mom too
and he knows that she might betray him
it's expected of pirates
however we know that luffy is not like
that not all pirates are the same
luffy is one who lives honorably and by
his principles he's a man of his word
and by this point kinemon has learned
that too not only does kinemon say that
luffy is different from kaido
he even says that luffy will stand on
the top of the sea
aka be the pirate king even if the
scabbards die
luffy will make sure don comes to wano
luffy like the scabbards
aside from kunjuro obviously proved that
you can live in an honorable way
not everyone is just concerned with
preserving their own life or being on
the winning side
then we jump to the other yonko and
luffy and i can barely believe i'm
saying those words
because it means that we're
significantly into this multi yonko
level war
big mom asks luffy why he came to wano
and tells him not to say something
ridiculous like he came here to defeat
kaido and luffy agrees to everyone's
shock
people are like yo luffy don't tell me
you changed your mind you're a rock
if you showed out wtf are we gonna do
but
luffy in another iconic moment for the
ages doubles down even triples down on
his confidence
he's not here to defeat kaido to just
defeat kaido that is he's also here to
defeat big mom
the commanders orochi and all of his
subordinates he's not
making any compromises or taking any
prisoners he's come to mop the floor
with all of them
and i can't but help have a big stupid
grin on my face when i read this
talk about falling off the horse and
getting back up luffy got bodied by
kaido
and he comes back confident that he can
beat kaido another yonko
all the commanders and more what an
absolute boss
he proclaims this is an all-out war and
that's what we've been waiting for
another war
a bigger and more significant one than
even marine ford
now to be fair it may be too early to
make a statement like that but i truly
believe it will be big mom laughs at the
idea of a few hundred people
accomplishing anything and so does queen
but when there's word of thousands of
intruders
we get some classic queen eye-popping
action the surprise attack was
definitely successful
although i still can't see big mom being
worried we get prisoners of udon
samurai zorro kid former warlord law
and perhaps most shockingly we see marco
the phoenix and pero sparrow together in
the entrance
not described as fighting but as
together for some reason
implying that pero sparrow who wasn't
crazy about the idea of an alliance with
the beast pirates
might actually help take them down as we
could have guessed
as the arc continues the prospect of the
straw hat somehow pulling out the w
keeps becoming more and more plausible
slowly but surely nonetheless
the seemingly impossible feat of taking
down a yonko
is seeming less and less impossible as
different puzzle pieces keep falling
into place
then again showing how much damn
influence and respect luffy has among
the yonko kaido says that he hurt and
accepts his challenge
in his dragon form now he says he'll
show luffy
and probably everyone else the world's
strongest power
if that ain't one of the most hyped
sentences ever spoken
i don't know what is we get a beauty of
a panel with kaido's dragon form
in front of the full moon his dragon
form like shenron is
towering over the scabbards giving us a
sense of how difficult how gigantic the
task in front of them
is kind of wants to fight outside where
there's more space and of course
this was accounted for kaido mentions
that odin is dead though
so he doesn't expect much of a fight
from the retainers but there are more
differences now than odin just not being
present
the retainers are stronger than they
were before and
in from the full moon all of the mink
tribe warriors will be able to undergo
the sioux long transformation
where in a werewolf-esque manner they'll
become much
much stronger nekomamushi looks
absolutely diabolical
in what must be a reference to alice in
wonderland and i
absolutely love it we are about to see
something epic ladies and gentlemen we
are witnessing history
in the making and i hope you all feel as
blessed as me for getting to experience
it and that is it for today's review we
had kaido bleed
showing the strength of the scabbards
but also the weakness of kaido
like when goku let down his guard and
got penetrated by a laser gun
kaido is weaker when he's in his
mentally unstable ptsd state
that is another way in which odin
continues to help the others
in this fight even from beyond the grave
kaido is clearly better now and he's
sober
too so we still haven't seen nothing yet
especially not the strongest power in
the world
that kaido hinted at we're also going to
see opie soolong transformations
including of characters like nekomamushi
and inuarashi who could fight the
all-star commander
jack without even entering into it this
is gonna be hella crazy as
luffy said when he mentioned kicking
everyone's butt this is all a war baby
and it's exciting af
as always let me know your thoughts on
these latest developments
and where you see us going from here if
you did enjoy this one piece review and
want to keep them coming
smash that like button to let me know
turn it blue like jimbei
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial ring that notification
bell or you will miss future one-piece
reviews and as you impatiently wait for
the next chapters to drop
feel free to check out my growing one
piece playlist where i got videos about
the yonko warlord supernova zone logia
and paramecia fruits
and even a video about how strong kaido
is you can find all those videos
and more by clicking the link in the
description a very special thank you
goes to our patrons over on patreon who
helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost i want to
thank the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord tuigo himself
alpha and are the one tier patrons the
ones who stand atop
all clans stephen and grana autumn the
world steelers acquire respect pate hepa
jonathan king brandon of isles papa
smurf emperor otaku
thomas jones and kenmono and our pro
hero tier patrons the one and only
gilgamesh who's the current most donated
overall champion
of the world nothing but a fan jason
wilson king zeldris anatoly kazatsky
angel cruz
cricket xp joe stanton very gucci alicia
actor
jessica kayla font hinokami and water
bonnie parks rethuan deyora deadly saint
and
stern hawkins thank you all so much if
you enjoy our work you can support more
of it by going over to patreon.com
anime pro and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here and you'll even get access to
our private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime outpour link in the description if
you're interested you can also now join
the youtube channel by clicking that
blue join button next to the subscribe
button that you've hopefully already
destroyed so yeah you can support more
content that way if you prefer whichever
way you choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you